on n'a pas vu cela que je voulais pas
travailler plaquage le pied n'a pas
beaucoup travaillé le pied
il aurait pu choisir le basket le
handball ou le foot mais il préfère les
plaquages au tacle méchant des lots
reprise de volée et les essais au but
tandis que du foot non pourquoi
parce que ça simule c'est pas ou quoi
enfin c'est pas le meilleur sport
parce que il n'y a pas beaucoup de
passes et je les pieds s'est pas montré
dans cette école de rugby on pratique de
3 à 13 ans sandro lui en est à sa
quatrième année et chez lui le rugby
c'est une affaire de famille c'est mon
frère je chaque entraînement je vais le
regarder
ça m'a plu j'aime bien l'esprit d'équipé
la collectivité
j'aime bien manipuler débat loin l'a
fait jouer
oui elle est belle salle à bompas parle
d'abord par des phases indique donc de
la motricité et beaucoup de jeu et on ne
parle pas chez les petits que le rugby
est proprement dit on les amène par le
jeu à des pratiques petit à petit au
rugby dans une région qui n'est pas une
terre d'ovalie le repli gagne pourtant
du terrain à l'école du rc haut on n'a
jamais eu autant d'adhérents et ce
malgré la crise sanitaire
le malheur des uns fait le bonheur des
autres on a eu la chance nous de faire
du sud de pardon de pratiquer du sport
en plein air donc on a permis de
récupérer des adhérents qui faisait du
sport en salle voilà tous les voyants
sont au vert il ya le quinze de france
qui a un peu sur un nuage qui vient de
faire le grand chelem
mais forcément ça donne aussi des
vocations pour pour les petits et puis
au delà de l'aspect sportif le rugby
c'est surtout comme on dit l'école de la
vie et ça ça plaît beaucoup aux parents
le respect vis-à-vis des éducateurs le
respect vis-à-vis des copains joueurs et
le respect aussi vis-à-vis de l'adulte
dans sa généralité c'est un sport avec
des très très bonne valeur se trouve au
niveau sportif pour avoir connu d'autres
aux sports est vraiment je trouve que
c'est très très intéressant
avec 115 enfants inscrits 400 licenciés
au club dé prochainement la création
d'une équipe féminine le rc aux pros
mais plus que jamais de faire vibrer les
tribunes